As proven by its enduring popularity on Netflix,
The Office has taken its place in the canon
of television classics, shedding the notion
that it was somehow an inferior remake to
its British counterpart.
Instead, it revolutionized TV comedy in ways
that nobody expected — or even really noticed.
For the vast history of American television
comedy, the laughs have come via a tried and
true formula: exposition, then a joke set-up,
and then the joke.
Cue the laugh track.
The Office turned that formula upside-down.
Its comedy wasn't joke driven, but situational
and character-driven, coming from relatable,
realistic interactions.
And, as in real life, those give-and-takes
are sometimes extremely awkward and uncomfortable.
"I'm supposed to be meeting someone named
Michael."
"Oh, that's not — yeah, I'm not…"
"Michael?"
"Michael."
It's a concept called "cringe comedy" because
audiences may literally squirm as the characters
on screen do awful but hilarious things that
would be unbearable in real life.
When Michael Scott fails to deliver on his
years-long promise to pay for college for
a bunch of kids, it's extremely uncomfortable.
"Who here has done something stupid in their
lives, like skipped out on study hall or mixed
up the difference between A gym and B gym,
that sort of thing?
Show of hands?
Anybody?"
It's also very funny because it's so over-the-top
terrible — it doesn't feel like a contrived,
silly sitcom premise because it seems like
just the kind of boneheaded mistake of which
only Michael Scott is capable.
Although there were certainly earlier examples,
like Curb Your Enthusiasm, The Office perfected
and popularized cringe comedy for network
TV.
For decades, nearly all sitcoms were produced
in the "three-camera" or "four-camera" format,
in which many cameras would remain mostly
stationary and capture whatever happened on
a well-lit, fake-looking set.
That style made episodes of everything from
Cheers to Everybody Loves Raymond feel like
little stage plays.
While that method persists on shows like Mom
and The Conners, most sitcoms now go for a
realistic feel, eschewing the artificial and
saturated look of videotape for the warmer
look of film.
They also shoot like a movie, with individual
shots of actors acting and reacting instead
of performing all at once on a soundstage.
While a few examples of this "single-camera"
style existed before The Office, from Malcolm
in the Middle to The Andy Griffith Show, the
format exploded after The Office presented
itself as a shot-on-film fake documentary.
A slew of sitcoms in the years since have
utilized a single-camera style since a "documentary
crew" took us inside Dunder Mifflin Scranton
— including the likes of New Girl, Community,
Brooklyn Nine-Nine, and tons of others — and
it has become the dominant format in a way
it never was before.
With the instant popularity of shows like
Big Brother and Survivor, reality TV took
off on American television around the turn
of the new millennium.
And then it stuck around, becoming a permanent
TV genre.
That represented a major shift: American TV
had quickly evolved from fully-scripted fare
to include programs ostensibly based on real
people in real situations, captured by ever-present
camera crews.
Something needed to come along to reflect
and comment on this rapid cultural development,
and that something was The Office.
It responded to reality TV by mocking it.
"But seriously, you made a nine-year documentary,
and you couldn't once show me doing my origami."
The show's original premise became a bit obscured
over time, but the Scranton branch of Dunder
Mifflin was the subject of a TV documentary
called An American Workplace.
The Office was a "mockumentary" in the style
of films like This is Spinal Tap and Best
in Show, and that style pointed out that viewers
shouldn't take actual reality TV too seriously.
With The Office laying the groundwork, that
fake documentary/mock reality show became
a prominent subgenre of comedy.
The producers and network behind The Office
recognized early on that the way people consumed
TV was changing fast.
It's fitting that The Office became such a
hit on a streaming platform like Netflix,
because during its run, the show was one of
the first available via the internet.
In 2005, Apple expanded its iTunes Store and
line of iPod music players to include video.
Users could pay a couple of bucks and download
an episode of a show, allowing them to watch
it on their computers when they wanted, or
on the go on a brand new video-enabled iPod.
It sure beat taping episodes with a VCR, and
was even more technologically advanced than
a DVR.
NBC was one of the first networks to sign
on for this way to make money off of the shows
viewers could otherwise watch on TV for free,
highlighting The Office as a downloadable
option.
In addition to directly changing the way TV
is conceived, filmed, and distributed, The
Office has another legacy: its cast and crew
scattered around Hollywood and became powerful
content creators.
Steve Carell became an A-list actor, thanks
in part to a big 2005 — The Office debuted
just a couple of months before The 40-Year-Old
Virgin hit movie theaters.
Along with a bunch of big movies, he's stayed
busy behind the scenes on TV.
He even co-created the silly TBS comedy Angie
Tribeca, starring and produced by his former
Office co-star Rashida Jones, who has also
worked behind the scenes on movies like Celeste
& Jesse Forever and Toy Story 4.
John Krasinski became a filmmaker, directing
movies like A Quiet Place.
Mindy Kaling left The Office, where she both
portrayed Kelly Kapoor and served as a writer,
to create more TV, including The Mindy Project.
And speaking of making TV happen, former Office
writer Michael Schur — a.k.a. Mose Schrute
— co-created three beloved and critically-acclaimed
comedy shows: Parks and Recreation, Brooklyn
Nine-Nine, and The Good Place.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.